[Music]
thank you very much for joining us today
you know I think it's it's very
interesting always to have a perspective
of the host country and perhaps a little
bit more broadly the Benelux area so I
would just turn first to you Alex euro
Fiber is present both in the Dutch as
well as in the Belgium markets so I
wonder what key market developments do
you see in these two markets and also
are there any real remarkable
differences that you will highlight
there are some obvious similarities as
well but what would you highlight as
differences between the two markets yeah
there are some remarkable similarities
especially if you see these these slides
you have correct coax networks
nationwide you have copper and fiber
networks nationwide by incumbents so
effectively both countries have two type
of incumbents operators what's really
exciting is deployment of fiber in the
enterprise market is growing pretty
quickly in both markets both the
Netherlands and Belgium what's also
exciting is there's an increasing
promise to deploy more fiber to the home
specifically in the Netherlands which is
really going so I think shake things up
in the Netherlands in the last let's say
three to five years you saw the charts
there have been investment in fiber to
the home and I think it's unfair to not
give credit to the various regional and
local players who are investing in fiber
home in the Netherlands in Belgium it's
a bit different in Belgium there haven't
really been that many investments in
fiber to the home Proximus did announce
recently that they were going to deploy
on a massive scale G Pond and other
interesting development is people are
talking about Jeep on now whereas four
or five years ago they weren't I think
in technologically that's been a change
and another interesting factor in
Belgium is there was announcement
recently by lluvias which is in a
utility company that they would also
deploy fibre to the home so that's
actually a public finance company
announcing that they would deploy fibre
to the home and effectively compete with
Proximus the only other real difference
and I look at Flanders and Vilonia
differently because they have very
different network infrastructure is the
the government financing of the
operators in Belgium is very different
the government financing operators in
the Netherlands I'm not necessarily
saying that has an impact on policy but
it is a fact in terms of financial
shareholder ship in the in the main
operators very good Michael and with
regard to the Belgium market what would
you see is the key trends within the
market what's changing also within the
market as we look forward and what's
triggering that change so for the latest
fear the key trends is the growing part
of creditable play and from 6% of the
bundles in 2013 to about 30% four years
later now with the broadband only remedy
we've imposed in our latest market
analysis on cable operators the markets
could start a move towards bundles
without television components and on the
last one I have to say it's a little too
soon to jump to conclusion but we have
observed different agreements on five
different commercial agreements on fiber
and it's too soon for two reasons the
first reason is that fiber rolled in in
Belgium is still not significant yet and
the second reason is that all those
commercial agreements do not represent a
significant market share but maybe this
is the first step to to co-investment
thank you shall we we have discussed
with Roberto earlier today quite in some
detail the the new code and the
potential impact of the new code
obviously the new code now introduces
four national regulators an additional
regulatory objective of incentivizing
investment in very high capacity and
that works and it does provide you with
new sort of tools and rule
so as a national regulator who will
actually have to put this into place and
apply it to national markets how do you
see the role of national regulators in
the role of national regulation actually
evolving in light of the changes of the
new code yes in India you're right
the codes sets an ambitious targets
regarding to the deployment of very high
capacity networks so in the codes
promoting the very high capacity net
rows becomes an explicit duty for
regulators to take into consideration
when contemplating regulation because in
the past regulators had to promote
infrastructure competition in the first
place
now this new duty could mean that the
the balance between the different
regulatory objectives competition and
users right and internal market could
move towards investment so this could
affect the way to regulate SMP operator
in the future and ensuring for for new
entrants access to today and the
networks of SMP operator may become
could become a lower priority but this
being said we have already taken this
new duty this new objective into
consideration in our latest market
analysis and broadband and television in
June last year we indeed did not we did
not impose a passive remedy we did not
obliged to change the topology of the
forthcoming fibre network of the the
incumbent like in the past when there
was a clear and bundling obligation we
allowed to use vectoring in order to
foster competition between cable and
VDSL and in current regular
we're even deregulated in the the areas
where the so called the wide so and so
the the we deregulate it in order to
stimulate the investment in the in this
white zone now
when you you look at the codes and an in
particular article seventy access to the
text is the first remedy to consider
however in Belgium there are very few
texts
that's why is it superheroes previously
the copper network was buried
underground and cable was installed on
the outside of the buildings and ftth
now is even if the coverage is limited
that you know if the th is also
installed on the outside of the building
when when possible of course now maybe
another topic it's about co-investment
co-investment in a theory it could be an
and is a good way to share risks and to
promote competition but the conditions
associated to co investment schemes are
quite demanding in the code that's the
reason why as a regulator we do not
think that co-investment
could represent a major change compared
to the existing regulation which impose
to be open to additional co-investors in
the future so maybe it's co-investment
more relevant for 5g outro in the past
we've tried to help a potential
co-investors to to reach an agreement
but after month of trials and discussion
bilateral multilateral we didn't succeed
so we'll SMP operators be more motivated
in the future to co-invest I'd I don't
know all I can say is that in the
currents regularly
we enabled lighter regulation in areas
where operator co-operators co-invest
and in the meantime the regulation will
prevail as long as operators do not
enter into negotiation on co-investment
Aleks within the code it's very clearly
a strong focus on fiber based delivery
for very high capacity networks but in
particular there's a slant towards the
importance of separated wholesale open
access networks why do you think that's
being viewed favorably as the successful
approach it's quite interesting because
it's something that we've been doing for
the last 15 years wholesale open
networks and I think there are three
main reasons as to why they're
successful and as three main reasons as
to why they're gaining momentum the
first is the proposition the proposition
is very clear for everyone you deploy a
network and your only goal is maximal
utilization yeah so you want as many
customers on there as possible many
wholesale providers on those possible
but also potentially end customers who
purely want access to that pure
connectivity layer those wholesale
customers are not concerned that you'll
compete with them somewhere else in the
value chain at a later stage either for
the residential customer or for the
business customer that's one the second
one is operationally of running a
business that is purely focused on
connectivity is a lot simpler than
running a fully integrated telco with
networked active layers and service
provision and and and tech so your
operating model is a lot more simple
which means which makes it easier to
really focus on your core business and
to deploy networks faster design
networks faster and maintain networks
better
that leads to the third point which is
the financing and it was referred to in
a previous session investors are
increasingly looking at connectivity as
a utility and as such different types of
investors are coming to the stage we've
seen various different phases of
investors over our 15 years it's now
much more the pension funds more the
infrastructure investors much a lot
longer
term horizons lower cost of capital and
patience money and as a result they're
more willing to invest in that part of
the business more so than the highly
competitive with the technology risk
part which is related to a vertically
integrated telco and that's sorry that's
just it's just the way these three
elements are now just working together
and that's where you starting to see an
influx of new models very good very good
and we're certainly seeing the impact of
that across many countries now so yeah
we saw examples you know with CDC is a
good example there was another one as
well and people are willing to take
significant risks on actually splitting
off this layer of connectivity versus
services
Michael Belgium is one of the few
countries where the cable infrastructure
has been opened up as a regulated at
wholesale access infrastructure and what
role do you see the cable infrastructure
really having you know as part of the
longer-term strategy from a regulatory
standpoint yep as in the Netherlands of
course cable is historically an
important market player and it will play
a major role on the roads to reach the
targets of the European Commission on
gigabit society
now given the duopoly structure of the
Belgium market access to cable is
crucial you know in order to ensure
competition and so as long as an axis at
fair condition cannot be secured by
commercial agreement it is necessary to
to impose access on both infrastructure
fibre VDSL on the one hand and cable on
the only on the other end now another
element since July 2017 in the Belgian
government has imposed a new procedure
called easy switch in order to ease the
change - from one Operator to another
operator especially when this change
implies a change of technology for
instance your customer of a cable
operator and
to change for VDSL fiber operator of or
vice versa as a regulator will have to
make an appraisal after two years of
this proceed procedure because we've
noticed that for the main part changes
occur among the same technology
wholesale access regulation I mean it is
a tough job for a regulator but I think
what what really matters ultimately for
investors in particular is the setting
of wholesale access prices that that's a
really tough task in in VIP tees
currently deliberating the level of
reasonable wholesale access prices so
obviously you can't comment on on that
actual ongoing procedure and wouldn't
ask you to do that but but more broadly
what are the key considerations that in
your view a regulator really needs to
take into account when setting those
regulated wholesale access prices yes in
indeed
public consultation on the the modeling
of fiber networking on the modeling of
cable network was conducted in December
last year till the February this year
and the currents results for access to
cable is about 16 euro for for excessive
about services and 23 for for access to
fiber but now the the costs resulting
from the model have to be translated
into an appropriate and tariff structure
with for for instance a possible
rebalancing between access and traffic
or and a possible tearing in function of
a broadband speed or possible tariff of
volume usage and it is or intention to
launch a new public consultation this
Tyner cost per non-tariff before summer
holiday
Alex obviously investor is not only the
regulated investors but also the
unregulated investors are impacted by
wholesale access price regulation so but
my question to you is that in light of
the regulatory environment in in both
markets who do you see currently really
investing in fibre what players are
investing in how has this fiber
investment seen been changing over the
last couple of years I think if you look
at the regional fiber-to-the-home
players invested in Netherlands they
tend to be backed by either
infrastructure funds or PE funds sorry
all pension funds I think to be fair I
mean people don't talk about and
certainly that last slide didn't really
do it much justice but I mean if I look
at who I'm competing with I compete with
kpn predominantly and so I know kpn is
investing a lot in fibre because I'm
competing I'm losing to them and so they
are competing as much as we are and
investing as much if not more as we are
in fibre to anything that's not
necessarily a consumers end goal and if
we thinking about economic activity and
improving that for the Netherlands
they're investing as much as we are if
not more so I think it will be wrong to
say that it's net it's not coming from
the incumbents but increasingly it's
coming from these pension funds and it's
increasing it's coming from the
infrastructure funds and as I said
earlier they just have a very different
view as to water require attorneys and
they're comfortable with the asset class
now there's more money coming on stream
the funds that are being raised a larger
and larger and larger and they need to
deploy that capital and as a result that
money is moving in towards fiber in the
Netherlands into Belgium but also across
Europe and and beyond and our
shareholder has invested in four fibre
companies in the last 12 18 months and
now they're deploying billions mostly in
the open wholesale model Alex for Fiber
operators and for ambassadors in general
what opportunities do you see really
emerging now with 5g coming over the
hill
and in particular on the context of
convergence what impact do you think
that will have on the industry yeah I
think it's really interesting because
it's a sort of a you know we don't need
to talk about fiber and five g 5g
requires fiber and no one's disputing
that I think that the discussion is
going to be the pace because people will
start to upgrade their core networks
before and make them 5g ready before
they really go into small cells and
that's when the fiber demand comes in
with regard to convergence there was a
discussion earlier around you know can
you have feel for 5g networks in a
country I don't think you can
from our perspective because we're
neutral we deploy a network and we allow
all operators to use it so for us it's a
huge opportunity but I don't think there
also will not be one 5g network I don't
believe there'll be one central shared
5g network for a whole country I think
you'll probably end up having pockets
and the speed of deployment will also
depend on the speed of deployment of
fiber to the home because there is a
very clear link between those two no
question and when some countries have
been further ahead in fiber to the home
that will impact house quickly they
deploy 5g and vice versa if there's no
fibre to the home and 5g might be the
first stepping stone so you will see in
different countries in different
geographies a different pace but the
fibre to the home and 5g will come
together and I don't believe that every
single operator will deploy their own 5g
network thank you very much well ladies
and gentlemen Fred were out of time now
at this point for this particular
session but please give a warm thank you
for our panelists
[Applause]
you